[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cynthia sa maman chérie j'ai dormi chez
man on n'a pas dormi chez toi qui a une
fois encore épaté fracas est ce que tu
étais pas qu'un autre camion qui pensent
qu'elle est telle qu'un tout petit donc
a réussi un assist
le plus petit le plus petit je vous dis
droit mais leur attaque à son tour
d'abord simca 5 bat manon sétoise du to
xiii bis tout à fait toi fais toi
[Applaudissements]
ouais maman ouais mais non ça va me
dérange quoi tu joues pas parce que là
là où j'étais en train de regarder la
métrique et je sais pas si tu l'as vu un
montcuq
[Rires]
j'enrage voilà j'adore j'adore voyager
en musique tient une tenue exprès pour
vous sachez le royal mail a parlé c'est
ce qu'on aime pour nous ce qu'on aime
ici c'est les entrées
[Musique]
c'est horrible ce que vous faites faire
oui nico ça va depuis tout à l'heure
dis moi je viens d'avoir cyrine du coup
pour la table alors il n'y a aucun souci
avec toi mais tu es pas dessus ce soir
mais du coup j'ai une proposition à
faire j'ai tu me dises ça te tente ou
pas quand tu me disais que voulait me
voir à la radio est ce que ça te dit de
venir leur a d'abord je voulais proposer
de venir dîner avec moi et dallas
l'armement suis pas content le faire une
prochaine fois qu'on prend en tête je
comprends pas une prochaine parce que
non je pense pas je pense pas mais bon
c'est dommage mais ce serait bien film
nous fait le qu il y soit instituée sur
l'interview bon je suis désolé pour les
enfants du coup me tuer sur la table
soit l'état prendra je t'ai dit la
vérité
est-ce que déjà est-ce que tu promis
nous
lui en ce moment
etc et non en fait c'est juste 10 chez
les jeunes et non mais on part dans une
mission où on essaie de les trouver une
mauvaise passe qui est en série
d'accords et et serrer les vis et
cosmétiques et rassure sursaut il m'a
dit moi si je l'appelle s'apaisa revit
ici car c'est moi ils les chroniqueurs
et s'est énervé parce que moi je n'ai
pas beaucoup donc tu vois
non mais si mon échelle sur une échelle
mais je m'occupe de tout dans cette
société
c'est à dire en pleine forme mais
pourquoi tu crois qu'il est mou quoi
maintenant il n'est pas bien bas grâce
qu'il cherche je cherche une mauvaise
mais c'est qu'en amour
[Musique]